[Music]
so that's who almost clipped us back
there hey look at that
got their own language out here their
own culture even with these cars
everything gets stripped away it's pure
speed time luke you broke your record
broke
it's about breaking through it's a race
against yourself check out the divisions
you got your classic rods your imports
special construction diesel trucks
rocket-powered cars it's crazy they
probably even have a ranking boat track
i don't normally spend my time trying to
mow the likes of you into a racing
machine
that said we suddenly find ourselves
with the rare opening on our team
huh and so you may accept the privilege
of racing for me no no no no no no we
are just passing after fantastic what no
perfect let's begin your journey peter
why are you doing this i've always
wanted to go faster and faster shoot
right now i got a pretty good shot at
what what do we know about these
crackpots
uh i mean these perfectly reasonable
racing professionals
[Music]
look at me
come on let's talk about this buddy i've
mastered advanced and quicker to twitch
watch out for the speeder
[Music]
175 miles per hour
465 miles per hour
640 miles per hour
[Music]
hey mater wanna race uh well come on
look at you all charged up the race but
i don't have a chance of getting out
come
hey buddy on letting you know i'm gonna
be gone because i'm heading back east to
go to my sister's wedding wait a minute
you have a sister whoa goggles of mine
man must be ages since you've seen her
what if i'd go with you really let's
make it a road trip
there's thousands of things to see
which is the tiniest little taste of
death
oh dear mother
i'm guessing this is the beginning of
something great you got that right
well under the backroads this is so cool
make new friends
where are you guys headed
i gotta rinse off this old baggage ah
whoa
look at you
what about me
can't mess with perfection
i spy with my little eye
quickity kitty cars
points for pageantry
[Music]
this is not what i expected
all the bumps along the road
that's what makes life worth living
[Music]
i love these i don't know come on look
you picked the last stop world's largest
tire maze mcqueen mater mcqueen mater
mcqueen
[Applause]
[Music]
bye